winter Wonderland's popping up all over
town but this one's got to be the
coolest literally Rocky is showing us
how minus five Ice Bar transforms for
the holidays
if outside it wasn't cold enough for you
you can come in here to a 23 degree
weather at the -5 Ice Bar this is where
you can really have a legit Winter
Wonderland 100 where else in the Mojave
Desert can you come during Christmas
time and get the true feel of what
winter is all about exactly so tell
everybody how you guys have transformed
the vice bars into a holiday party or
Christmas party we have Christmas
decorations all throughout the venue we
have an awesome holiday sculpture here
as well that you can get your Christmas
photo come on Caitlin Caitlin our intern
we were taking her pictures for her
Instagram yeah friendly as well as you
know have a group shot with the boys so
that you know girls trip whatever you
have here we have a lot of bachelorette
parties Bachelor parties throughout the
weekends we have snow machines on the
top so if you're outside on the link
Promenade here and there every on the
half hour you'll see the snow blowing
everywhere throughout the Promenade and
we have a lot of holiday drinks to offer
as well here and holiday drinks we also
have themed parties so tell everybody I
know you guys can come down for
throughout the holidays but also New
Year's Eve right yes on New Year's Eve
we will have drinking around the world
every hour we will celebrate a different
country celebration free champagne toast
for whoever's in the venue at that time
that's
awesome we're looking at our level here
enjoying is this your first time
yeah it's cold huh
I love it they're enjoying their holiday
drinks um but you know we'll also have
throughout the holidays the Grinch and
the yeti will make an appearance yes
they uh come out probably at least every
hour or two you'll see them and it's
awesome it really brings the vibe of the
Ice Bar up and feel free to take
pictures and whatnot mess around with
the yeti and the Grinch what we have to
do is make sure they don't get into the
bar yes of course they make sure they
stay out on the floor they get behind
the bar we might have some issues but
feel free to buy your tickets online or
if you want to come by at the store we
sell tickets every day 11 to midnight on
the weekdays 11 to 2 A.M on the weekends
perfect you guys this is the realest
holiday party you can get okay it is 23
degrees in here at the minus five Ice
Bar this is where you can celebrate with
cocktails coats up until January 2nd yes
100 feel free to buy our VIP package
comes with the hats photos two drinks
and the fur coat as well really uh
creates the experience for you once
again AJ you're trying to show off with
no coat on it just a little bit you want
me to roll the sleeves up a little more
I can't coming up we're gonna get into
these holiday cocktails